hi everyone my name is Rachel and I'm a
PhD student in the autonomous systems
lab and in the Stanford vision and
learning lab and today I'd like to talk
about incorporating sample efficient
monitoring into learned autonomy
and the motivation behind this is that
in a lot of robotic systems with
learning enabled components the cost of
failure is really high
so for instance in autonomous driving a
collision could kill people
in a healthcare setting a wrong
diagnosis could lead to the wrong
treatment and for a robot on the factory
floor these robots are working alongside
people and we don't want them to cause
injuries and these are just a few
examples of critical high-stakes
applications and in these types of
settings it's really important to be
able to have Warning Systems that will
issue an alert when an unsafe situation
is imminent
but these systems are really complex so
guaranteeing safety is not really
something you can do from first
principles so we need empirical
data-driven methods
so in this talk I'm going to present two
ways of addressing this problem
in the first part of the talk I'll
introduce a real-time warning system
framework for detecting unsafe
situations when there's no distribution
shift
for example in a driver assistance setup
the system could provide a warning when
you're about to crash or something like
that
but one limitation of this method is
that the distribution of the unsaved
samples needs to be the same between the
training and test data and so in order
to deal with that in the second part of
this talk I'll present a method for
detecting distribution shifts
so for instance if we have an autonomous
vehicle deployed and the weather changes
over time or we have sensor degradation
over time the warning system from part
one might not work and we'd be we'd like
to be able to detect that
okay so I'll start with the warning
system framework for detecting unsafe
situations
the relevant paper for this part of the
talk is called sample efficient safety
assurances using conformal prediction
and this paper is on archive and like I
mentioned earlier in this work we
introduced a real-time warning system
framework for detecting unsafe
situations and this framework is
specifically designed for robotics
applications and it can provide safety
guarantees even when there's not very
much data available
here's the high level overview of how we
approach the problem
and we're going to use a running example
throughout of a driver alert system so
in a car we might want to have a warning
system that will alert you every time
you're in danger of crashing and this
warning system could have errors which
could be false positives or false
negatives
and in this scenario false positives
would mean that you got some extra
warnings and a false negative would mean
that the system failed to warn you when
you're about to crash
so in this particular setting the focus
of this work is on providing a high
probability guarantee for how many false
negatives are allowed
and the way we do this is by collecting
a data set of training points of unsafe
examples running it through our system
and using the framework of conformal
prediction to provide guarantees
limiting the false negative rate and our
system makes these guarantees in a very
sample efficient way
so how do we get these guarantees
when people think about guarantees in
robotics we typically think about
confidence intervals and accurately
estimating error rates with statistical
learning theory but this method also has
some drawbacks namely sample complexity
if you want confidence intervals you
need a lot of data
but we could also think about guarantees
in a different way so we could try to
stack we could sacrifice trying to
estimate the false positive and false
negative rates exactly and instead
consider a more task-centric notion of
what if we care more about the false
negatives
and this one-sided guarantee is what's
important in this type of safety
critical system
so if the problem has this flavor then
we can use conformal prediction which is
a statistical tool that produce that
produces prediction sets such that the
true label is guaranteed to be within
the set with one minus Epsilon
probability
okay so now I'll go over our framework
more concretely
and as a reminder we're using a driver
alert system as our running example and
here's some of the notation that I'll be
using
so X represents the current observations
so here it might be the locations of
these cars
D represents the true unknown future
state of a system so in our example here
maybe this car moves here in the next
time step
y represents the predicted future state
of the system so maybe our model
predicts that this red car will actually
move here
F of Z is the true safety score and a
safety score is a user-defined metric
that determines safety so if the safety
score is too low then we consider a
situation unsafe in our example here we
Define it as the distance to the nearest
car so that would be this blue line here
G of Y is the surrogate safety score
which is also something that's
correlated with safety and in this
example the functions f and g are
actually the same so G is also the
distance to the nearest car but the
difference is that the input to G is the
predicted future state of the system y
rather than the true unknown future
state of the system Z so here that would
be this orange line here
F naught is the safety threshold so if
the safety score is below this threshold
then we consider the situation unsafe
and in our example that means that if
these if these two cars are too close
together then we consider the situation
unsafe
and what we like to do is design a
warning function such that given a
simulator output Y which is in bold here
our warning system either decides to
issue a warning
or not
and we'd like our warning system to
satisfy Epsilon safety which means that
if F of Z is less than F naught so if
these cars will be too close together
then we'll issue a warning with at least
one minus Epsilon probability
and so the goal is to design a warning
system that provably achieves Epsilon
safety for small Epsilon while achieving
a low false positive rate meaning that
we don't trivially always issue an alert
and the main difficulty here is that the
warning function can only depend on the
simulated future why rather than the
true future Z which is not yet observed
when the warning is issued and your
simulator might not come with any
performance guarantees
so here's our algorithm to achieve
Epsilon safety
first we'll compute a surrogate safety
score based on the simulator outputs for
each unsafe example in the training data
set so we might get a bunch of predicted
nearest distance scores here
then we'll compute the safety score for
the new test point and compute its
quantile value
so we look at the proportion of training
samples with a lower safety score than
the new test point and the idea is that
if I have a new unsafe example it should
look like my previous unsafe examples so
this new test score could fall anywhere
and the probability that it just happens
to be one of the largest scores is very
low so that allows us to bound the
probability that we have a false
negative
and so if this quantile value is smaller
than 1 minus Epsilon we emit an alert
and otherwise we don't
so like I just mentioned intuitively if
this is an unsafe example it's highly
unlikely that this quantile value is
higher than 1 minus Epsilon so you're
highly unlikely to not emit an alert if
this is an unsafe example
and the algorithm guarantee is that if
the training data and the new test data
point are exchangeable meaning that the
probability of observing any permutation
of the data is equally likely in other
words when you have a new unsafe sample
it looks like the old unsafe samples
also note that exchangeability is
actually a weaker assumption than the
standard IID assumption in statistical
learning theory so if the training data
and the new test data point are
exchangeable
then our algorithm is Epsilon plus one
over two plus one safe where T is the
number of unsafe examples
okay so I'd like to take a minute here
to discuss the trade-off between the
false negative rate and the false
positive rate and there are two
possibilities the infinite data regime
and the finite data regime and I'll
start with the finite data regime since
that's where we operate in the real
world
so in the finite data regime to
guarantee one over T safety we need at
least T samples
can we do better than this
we actually show that it's impossible to
do any better than this and we proved
that in general if there are fewer than
T data samples it's impossible to
guarantee better than o of 1 over T
false negative rate without incurring a
false positive rate of close to one and
since our algorithm can guarantee an O
of 1 over T false negative rate while
the false positive rate is low it's
asymptotically optimal
so that's the finite data regime but
even with infinite data we may not be
able to achieve both perfect false
negative rate and perfect false positive
rate
for instance in an adversarial case
imagine that the distribution of
surrogate safety scores for your unsafe
samples and your safe samples exactly
overlaps so that they their these
distributions are identical then it's
impossible to distinguish between the
two and you cannot get both a perfect
false negative rate and a perfect false
positive rate
um at The Other Extreme if these two
distributions are completely disjoint
then it would be possible to get a
perfect false negative rate and a
perfect false positive rate
the reality is probably somewhere in
between so maybe something like this
diagram shown here
where they overlap somewhat and so in
this case this dashed line is set by the
false negative rate of Epsilon that you
desire
and then the stash line determines the
the false positive rate which is this
blue area here and this is the lower
bound on the false positive rate even in
the infinite data regime
and but note that these distributions
are determined by the surrogate safety
score and real world data so you can
design your surrogate safety score such
that these distributions are further
apart and we'll and as we'll see in a
few slides we were able to design safety
scores such that the false negative rate
and false positive rate are both good
for several real world situations
okay so now I'll go over some
experimental results
um in the set of experiments we used a
we had a driver alert system where the
goal is to warn the driver of potential
unsafe situations
we used the new scenes and lift
autonomous driving data sets and we used
trajectron plus plus as our future
Dynamics model
we used a distance metric as our safety
score and a distance metric as predicted
by a trajectron plus plus as our
surrogate safety score
and here are some of our results
so in all of these plots the false
negative rate is in red the false
positive rate is in blue and the Epsilon
bound the desired Epsilon bound is in
green
and and so in this first plot we plotted
these error rates versus the safety
score threshold which is the distance at
which we're considering a situation
unsafe
in the second plot we plotted these
error rates versus the desired Epsilon
bound
in this third plot we plotted the error
rates versus the proportion of unsafe
situations in the training data set
and in this fourth plot we plotted the
error rates versus the desired Epsilon
Bound for the lift data set rather than
the new scenes data set and there are a
couple of things to note here
the first is that the false negative
rate is always within the theoretical
bound and this is done with very little
data new scenes only had 50 to 70 unsafe
examples in the training data set and
Lyft only had about 50.
the second thing to note is that the
false positive rate is generally quite
good and this is true even though we
used an off-the-shelf trajectory
predictor trained on a small academic
data set
and the third thing to note is that our
method is actually robust to label shift
and we can see that from plot C here so
the frequency of unsafe situations can
differ between the training and test
data because our algorithm depends only
on the unsafe examples
and we also have similar results in our
paper for a robotic grasping system
where the goal is to issue a warning
when the robot will fail to pick and
transport an object but I'll skip going
over that for now for the sake of time
and you can refer to our paper for more
details
so to summarize the first part of the
talk we introduced a broadly applicable
framework that uses conformal prediction
to provide safety assurances for Warning
Systems
we demonstrated empirically that the
false negative rate guarantees hold for
a driver alert system and a robotic
grasping system
and we empirically observed a low false
positive rate
okay so that method works pretty nicely
if the data distribution didn't change
and in that case our system will usually
do well and we can even give safety
guarantees like I just discussed
but what if there is a distribution
shift
in these scenarios not only do we get
worse do we not get these guarantees our
system might also perform worse so for
example here's an autonomous airplane
taxing system that fails and causes the
aircraft to go off the Runway when
daytime turns to night time so daytime
is on the left Night Time is on the
right and we can see on the right that
the airplane is veering Off The Runway
so we want to be able to actually
identify when the distribution shifts
and that brings me to the second part of
this talk which is a warning system for
identifying distribution shifts
the relevant paper for this part of the
talk is called online distribution shift
detection via recency prediction and
this paper is also on archive
so our goal here is to detect
distribution shift
in a streaming fashion this is useful
for robotics where data comes in online
quickly and with guarantees limiting the
number of false alarms because if there
are too many false alarms the warnings
will be ignored by the user and
therefore not useful in practice
and we're looking at gradually shifting
episodic situations for example for an
airplane that repeatedly taxes down a
Runway there could be gradual
distribution shift over time due to
sensor degradation and we'd like to
issue an alert before a major problem
occurs
so here's a high level overview of our
method
we again Target safety critical robots
like an autonomous aircraft using a deep
neural network for perception to taxi
down a Runway
and in this example the Deep neural
network used for perception is
unreliable under distribution shifts
like daytime to night time
so to improve safety we design a warning
system that detects distribution shifts
and we do this by training a neural
network to predict which samples are
more recent and issuing a warning when
the neural network is consistently able
to predict recency
okay so now I'll go over our method more
concretely
our approach is to design a test
statistic such that if the distribution
shifts this test statistic will grow and
we'll know that the distribution has
changed
so how can we get this kind of test
statistic
well martingales give us a very good
tool for doing this
okay so what is a Martingale well a
Martingale is a sequence of random
variables M1 M2 Etc such that the
expectation of m n plus 1 given M1
through MN is equal to MN
and they have this nice property
formalized by dube's inequality which
basically says that the probability of a
Martingale growing very large is very
small
for example the probability that a
Martingale starting at one grows larger
than 100 is less than one percent
okay so here's what we do
first we train a neural network model to
distinguish between older and newer
samples so we input two samples two
images one of them is more recent than
the other and we ask the neural network
model to do a binary prediction problem
and predict which one of these two is
newer
then we'll Define an indicator variable
y that will be 1 if the model predicts
correctly and zero otherwise
and if no distribution shift has
occurred then Y is a Bernoulli random
variable with P equals 0.5 so we can
define a Martingale as shown here and
the Martingale if there's been no
distribution shift the Martingale should
not grow
the intuition here is that if your
distribution didn't shift your
classifier should not be able to guess
whether a new sample is actually new
better than random chance
and therefore the probability that it
makes a correct guess is one-half and
because the probability is one-half then
we have a random walk and one thing we
know about random walks is that they're
unlikely to deviate significantly from
their mean by a standard concentration
results
and so more generally we use a
Martingale which is an extension of a
random walk
to make a test
and we know that the probability that
the martingdale grows large is very
small and that's how we can limit our
false positive rate
okay so now let's look at some
experimental results from this method
so to validate the performance of our
method we use image data from an
autonomous aircraft in a photorealistic
flight simulator that repeatedly taxes
down a Runway and here we have a gradual
daytime to night time shift
so this is the simulation of the plane
taxing down the runway in the morning on
the left evening on the right this is
the same one that I showed earlier but
just as a reminder the the shift causes
the airplane to Veer Off The Runway
but with our method we can actually
detect this shift within 13 episodes
so our method is in blue and note that
after 13 episodes the sky isn't even
Dark Yet
and meanwhile prior methods take much
much longer to detect this shift
so then we looked at a distribution
shift caused by a small change in the
camera angle and this could happen for
instance if a camera is knocked slightly
Askew so on the left we have the
calibrated camera and on the right we
have the perturbed camera
um it's only perturbed very slightly as
we can see here so first we change the
camera angle very slightly just that
much and this small change in camera
angle actually causes the plane to go
off the Runway in the upper right corner
is what would happen without this change
but we can see that with this change
this plane is going off the Runway
but our method also detects this
distribution shift and we can see from
this plot that when there is a
distribution shift the Martingale grows
very rapidly and when there is no
distribution shift the Martingale does
not grow
and we also find empirically that we
have a very low false negative rate in
our experiments each time there was a
distribution shift our method did
actually catch it
okay so to summarize this part of the
talk we designed a warning system that
detects distribution shifts on high
dimensional data rapidly and in an
online Manner and through extensive
experiments we validate that our
approach significantly outperforms prior
work
so to wrap up the contributions from
this talk we present two methods that
work together to help us safely deploy
robots in the real world the first
method is a warning system that issues
alerts when a robot encounters an unsafe
situation
um but its limitation is that it assumes
no distribution shift between the
unsaved samples in the training set and
in the test set and so to address this
limitation in the second method we
presented a method for quickly detecting
distribution shifts from data
encountered in the real world and taking
together these methods could lead to a
more robust robotic safety system
okay thank you and I'm happy to take
questions
yeah thank you for the next talk
um
in the distribution shift detector when
you were showing the example of your
method being able to detect uh the
distribution shift before it even like
visually looked like the sky was getting
dark does that mean that your method
would give like a warning of
distribution shift very early and maybe
before it's actually necessary to enact
any chain like reasonable change
important to that institution sure yeah
that's a great question and and yes that
would be the hope so uh like
so for situations like this where
there's like a gradual change over time
like like maybe you have gradual sensor
degradation or something like this the
hope is that if you catch this early on
then that's before like a massive
failure happens and you can uh you can
do something about this to fix the
situation before a big problem occurs
but
the model that you train like could you
talk about how you would train it for
um
it should be able to handle any type of
distribution shift so the way I trained
it uh first of all this is like a super
simple neural network model it was like
a four four layer neural network I
didn't do anything fancy at all to it
and I'm sure you could do better if you
tried harder on the architecture side
but um all I did was I I basically
divided the the training data which is
pre-distribution shift uh into like a
first half and a second half and uh I
took one point from the first half one
point from the second half these are
Pairs and I want to train the neural
network to be able to distinguish which
one is newer so when there's no
distribution shift like the neural
network like doesn't particularly learn
anything uh the accuracy is like one
half but as a like at test time I keep
adding new points to the second half
data so when there's a distribution
shift if the second how if the second
half data looks different than the early
data then the neural network should be
able to learn that they look different
and be able to get high accuracy
yeah so with this work if say there's a
sudden change so
yeah you trained it from morning to
afternoon maybe sadly there's a thick
cloud and it becomes very dark we'll be
able to
detect that
yeah so actually in our camera angle
example we it was a sudden change so the
method does work for sudden changes
there's nothing in the method that
prevents it from working on a sudden
change the reason we're trying to focus
on more gradual changes which I think
happen fairly often in robotics is that
if this very Sudden Change does cause a
catastrophic failure immediately even
though our method catches it within like
10 episodes maybe that's already too
late if a sudden change truly causes a
catastrophic failure so yeah our our
Focus the focus of this is sort of more
towards like gradual changes
foreign
after that would be if you can capture
that there is a gradual change can you
also capture through this method of what
this shift is
um
that would require more work yeah